[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi, everybody.
I'm Robin Young
from NPR and WBUR.
Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome to what I promise you is
going to be a fabulous evening.
I am so thrown back.
And even thinking
about Title IX,
I am just awash in
memories of starting
to run in 1965 when I was 15--
don't do the math, I'm 66--
15 years old, 1965.
I don't know where this
harebrained notion came from.
There were not even any
girls running shoes.
I had were boys' Tigers.
And you had to run at
night because people
would think you--
what were you running from,
you that you were crazy.
This was not that
long after people
thought that women's
lady parts would fall out
if we got too active.
So that's in the 60s.
You fast forward 10 years.
And I live right
around the corner.
And I get up and go
running every day.
And there's my new
friend, Susan Ware,
who's running on the same
street that I'm running.
We're going out to
the river in the '70s.
And Susan, of course,
is the Radcliffe scholar
who wrote the definitive
book on Title IX
and also curated the
exhibit at the Schlesinger.
And, Susan, how many Bonne
Bells in a row did you run?
You have a record.
25 Bonne Bells in
a row did she run.
So I encourage you--
there's so much here
for you, including
the Schlesinger Library
just two buildings down,
which is the leading library
on the history of women
in America.
And please visit Susan's exhibit
on Title IX that's over there.
It's titled Playing Fair--
Title IX at 45.
It's over from now
until September 15.
It's completely open
to the public and free.
And know that when you
are looking at that,
it's the work of
a 25-year-old who
was running up and down the
Charles so many years ago.
And then two years ago, Susan
came, always steeping herself,
trying to get as close as
possible to these women
in history that
she writes about.
She came over here on a summer
day and ran around that track
up there.
There is a track--
a women's running
track-- up there.
This building that we are in now
is the former Radcliffe College
gym.
It was built in 1898.
And Susan, you were saying
that being up there,
you had this spiritual
feeling of being
connected to women that were
running up there 100 years ago.
I was thinking--
when I come in here,
I always think of my dear
friends Alice Furlaud--
who was an NPR commentator
who passed away this year--
and her roommate,
Linda Cabot Black.
You may have seen Linda
around Cambridge--
she's a Cabot.
And every morning, she gets
up, puts on her sensible shoes,
takes her very
sensible stray dog,
and walks five miles up
and down the Charles River
picking up garbage.
But Linda and Alice were
roommates here in 1948.
And I love to think of these
incredible women climbing ropes
here in what was then the
gym or playing basketball.
We understand it must
have been half-court.
But we're just
sitting in this place
that has such a
history for us to take
on the topic of the night.
This of course is now
the Knafel Center.
It's the main meeting place
at what's now the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
For those of you
unfamiliar, it's
the successor to
Radcliffe College.
It's Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study.
Notice I said advanced
study, not just study--
advanced study here.
They share transformative ideas
from across all disciplines.
They have leading
experts from all fields
who share their knowledge,
invite the public in
to participate.
And by the way, at
WBUR we pride ourselves
on having the same mission--
sharing thoughts,
transformative thoughts,
across all disciplines and
inviting you the public in.
So we are thrilled to be
a partner of this evening.
And tonight's experts--
man, we were taken.
I said this is a tweet
waiting to happen.
We were back there, I
said, let's take a picture.
And the thing almost exploded.
There's so much power.
They are all
beneficiaries of Title IX,
which of course was the landmark
legislation enacted in 1972--
too late for me as a teenager.
But it mandated gender
equality for all institutions
receiving federal aid.
And that of course
changed opportunities
for all young women.
You didn't have to just
go stand on the balance
beam for hours at a time.
You could possibly be on teams.
And our panelists have
played basketball in college
and in professional
leagues, they've
won national championships
and Olympic medals.
From there, one has gone on to
a career in politics, another
into medicine, another
into business--
and I should of course note
another into journalism.
And the legacy of Title
IX is in the lives
that they are living today.
So before we even start, can
we have a round of applause,
please for the women
were about to meet.
[APPLAUSE]
Tonight we're going to celebrate
the upcoming 45th anniversary
of Title IX.
We're going to
explore its legacy
from all different
viewpoints, hear
from our outstanding
panelists and moderator,
and then you the audience.
Now to the moderator.
My dear friend Rick Carlisle--
and as often as I can, I
put that sentence together.
He's of course the
former Celtic and now
the coach of the
Dallas Mavericks.
So my dear friend Rick
Carlisle once said to me,
you know, there's this
Shira Springer girl.
You ought to keep an eye on her
because she is the real deal.
I did, she is.
Rick is known for being a quiet
mentor to many young women.
Shira blew him away.
She covered stories
at the intersection
of sports and society for 20
years at the Boston Globe,
reporting on all four major
Boston professional teams
plus the NBA finals, the
World Series, the Olympics,
the Boston Marathon.
She served as the Globe's
Celtics beat writer
for seven years then worked
as an investigative enterprise
reporter, Olympic columnist,
women's sports columnist.
Her coverage of the
Celtics and the NBA
as well as a larger sports
world earned her awards
from the Associated Press
and from the Women's Sports
Foundation for feature writing.
We are so lucky to
have her now at WBUR.
She grew up in Connecticut
competing in sports,
cheering on the New York
Mets, Hartford whalers.
Graduated from Hartford with
honors in social studies.
Ran cross-country
track in college.
Little bit of overachievement
going on here.
Now she runs marathons.
Can't wait to hear what
race might be next for her.
Rick Carlisle knew from what
he was talking about when
he spotted Shira Springer.
Please welcome Shira
and as she brings up
her panel for tonight.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Robin.
That was really too kind.
And I want to thank
Radcliffe and WBUR
for co-hosting this event.
Before I turn to tonight's
conversation and our panelists,
I want to go back to 1999.
It's two years after the
WNBA played its first game.
It's one year after women's
hockey made its winter
Olympic debut and
the US won the gold.
And I want to take you back
specifically to July 10, 1999.
You may remember that was
the day of the Women's World
Cup final in the Rose Bowl.
I was there.
I was lucky enough to have that
be one of my first assignments.
And what I remember
is a packed stadium--
90,000 people showed up
to see women's soccer.
You also may remember the game
ended in a penalty shootout,
5-4 US victory.
Brandi Chastain celebrates
by removing her shirt.
And you have that iconic image.
And I also remember
what happened afterwards
when I got to talk to the
players, and the coaches,
and some of the
administrators from US soccer.
And what I remember is that they
all saw this as a turning point
in women's sports,
that the game was
an affirmation of the gender
equity gains made since Title
IX's passage in 1972.
And there was a lot of talk not
only about the legislative part
of Title IX but about the
symbolic force of Title IX,
as something that made
women think about equality
of opportunity in
sports and outside
of sports and to think
about new possibilities.
And I think, as
we all know here,
there's still plenty
to talk about.
Because the turning
point in women's sports
never quite arrived
the way many envisioned
it would after July 1999.
Women's pro soccer leagues
have been established
and folded multiple times.
Women still lag behind
men in scholarship dollars
and participation.
Girls drop out of
high school level
sports at an alarming rate.
It's astonishing--
by age 14, they're
dropping out two
times as much as boys.
And there's still
inequality when
it comes to women in
the coaching ranks,
in the executive ranks, and
the general manager ranks,
and senior management in
various pro sports leagues.
So a lot of work to be done.
So tonight with our panel I
want to talk about Title IX
not just as the
legislative part of it
but as the symbolic part--
as the symbolic force, and
to use that as a jumping off
point for a conversation
about sports and gender
that will involve all of you.
And it's about more than
equality of participation.
To me, it's about
funding and marketing.
It's about opportunities
at the youth level,
getting better facilities.
It's interesting.
I was talking to Gevvie
about this panel.
And she was telling
me the story of how
the US women's
soccer team in 1999
fought to compete
in large venues.
The men on US soccer said,
oh, you'll never fill them,
you'll never fill them.
And the women said, no, we will.
Give us those 90,000
seat stadiums.
We'll put people in the seats.
And they did.
And then outside of sports
in a larger context,
the symbolic force of
Title IX, it made women--
and I don't think just
athletes, but women--
more aware of
inequalities and the fact
that they deserved bigger
roles and better treatment.
And we know that
statistics show that sports
plays an important role in
developing female leaders.
It's no surprise
to me, actually,
that when there was that
whole conversation-- well,
when the women's hockey team
and the women's soccer team
fought for pay equality this
past year that it mirrored what
was happening with
discussions across the nation
about the gender pay gap.
So anyways, that's the
way I see Title IX.
I'm excited to dive into
it with our panelists.
You may notice that Angela
Ruggiero is not here.
Sad to say, there was
a death in her family
and she couldn't make it.
But as I said, excited
for the three women
who are sitting beside me.
We have Maura Healey to my left.
You all know Maura Healey as
Massachusetts attorney general.
But before she became--
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, a round of
applause for that.
[APPLAUSE]
But before she became
attorney general,
did you know that she was
a 16-year-old trying out
for the women's national
basketball team?
There was some oohs
there, so maybe not.
She went on to captain the
Harvard women's basketball
team-- co-captain-- and
then played professionally
in Salzburg, Austria.
And now instead of dribbling
away from pressure,
she's taking on
pressure at the highest
levels of the political arena.
Now Swin Cash.
In her storied
basketball career--
I don't think storied
even describes it.
At the college
and the pro level,
she won seven championships--
two NCAA titles with UConn,
two Olympic gold medals,
and three WNBA championships.
But I have a feeling now she
may face her toughest challenge.
She's entering the
ranks of-- or she's
in the ranks of
basketball executives.
She is now the director
of player development
for the WNBA's New York Liberty.
And I know that's a-- it's
a tough job you've got ahead
of you.
And now Gevvie, Gevvie Stone.
I have to admit--
[APPLAUSE]
One of my favorite moments
covering the Rio Olympics
last summer was getting to
watch Gevvie stone win silver
in singles.
It was an amazing race.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
--I didn't expect it.
I don't know if you expected it.
But it was just one of
those thrilling moments
where I got to talk
with her beforehand
and I knew all the hard
work that had gone into it.
And just incredibly impressed.
She's a two time Olympian.
She's also assistant coach
of the Radcliffe crew.
And in one month, Dr Stone
will be starting her residency
in emergency medicine at
Beth Israel Deaconess.
And I'm going to guess you'll
probably still find time
to row on the Charles.
[APPLAUSE]
- Absolutely.
- So let's start with this.
I'll start a bit broadly.
And I'm going to
go to you, Maura.
Where would you be
without Title IX?
- Well, I certainly wouldn't
be attorney general.
And I say that not just because
I made that one commercial
where I spun a basketball--
[LAUGHTER]
--although that helped.
But I think that
sports really gave me
esteem and self-confidence.
I started playing
sports in the late '70s
through the '80s and
early '90s and was
a beneficiary of Title IX.
And a lot of ground
had already been
broken in terms of the
formation of youth sports teams
for girls.
And so I just think that as I
look back, sports and really
what was created
through Title IX, for me
it was about instilling
discipline, learning
how to compete as a girl--
I think that that's
important that we not
be afraid to compete.
And I think of so many
lessons along the way
that I learned from sports.
And it's clear to
me that I wouldn't
have had the experience
of coming to college here
and playing for Kathy
Delaney-Smith were it
not for what sports gave me
and continued to give me.
And even going to try out as--
I guess I was 5-4.
I've never really grown.
I think that's as far as I got.
I've been 5-4 since I
was in the eighth grade.
- Princeton listed you at 5-6.
- At 16 I thought
I was all that,
and went off to try out
for the national team,
and got a rude awakening.
But what was really cool
about that experience
was meeting women who had--
who I had idolized.
And to see women like that,
to be inspired by women
like that, definitely
motivated me.
I remember thinking, boy,
if Nancy Lieberman can
win four Olympic medals,
what can I do, you know?
And so I just am forever
grateful to sports
because of what it has
given me and the experiences
that it's given me.
- I'll go down the line with
Swin, if not for Title IX.
- I would echo that.
I think if it
wasn't for Title IX,
I wouldn't be
sitting here today.
I think Title IX for me
was a sign of opportunity.
And I think it led to having
this god-given ability to play
sports and compete.
But you can play sports
and compete when you
come from humble beginnings.
But if there's no opportunity
to take that to the next level,
you're just competing
in your neighborhood.
And so when my mom told me
at a young age that, hey,
I can't pay for you
to go to college.
But these people
are writing letters,
and they see you
playing basketball,
they see you doing track and
all these different things,
you have a real opportunity.
It's hard to understand
that message internally
as a young kid.
But my mother and I had
those conversations.
And so I tell kids all the time
now is that I used basketball,
basketball never used me.
Because the end game
for me was always
to use my sport to
get my education
and then to be able to
go out there in the world
and make a change.
And because of
basketball, I've been
able to do that
all over the world.
And that is to me
pretty remarkable
thinking where I came
from to where I am today.
- Gevvie?
[APPLAUSE]
- I also echo what
Swin and Maura said.
I think as a rower you grow up
with a very close relationship
with Title IX.
My mom rowed in the '70s with--
knew the Yale women who walked
into the athletic director's
office protesting.
And she raced the 1976
Olympics where they got garters
as part of their Olympic kit.
Needless to say that 40 years
later we were not getting
garters in our Olympic kit.
And I think that
change generationally
and growing up with a mother
who raced at the elite level was
very visible to me, how many
opportunities I got compared
to the one she got.
She went to Cal Berkeley, which
didn't have a women's rowing
program at the time.
So she transferred to
Cal State Long Beach
where she could row
at a local club.
And I just took it for granted
that I could apply to colleges
where I could row.
Not that I took it for granted.
I did appreciate it.
But it just-- the
number of opportunities
was so much greater at the
time that I got into the field.
And it enabled me to receive
an education at the same time.
And I got to grow as an athlete.
And that's why I am who I
am today is really that--
chasing that student
athlete dream.
- I'm curious if--
you mentioned you
had the benefit--
your mother experienced
things that you fortunately
did not have to experience.
And I'm wondering if you--
any of you personally have
experienced differences
in treatment that
have struck you.
I know actually, Swin, it wasn't
during your athletic career
but broadcasting right
where were the real gender--
- Oh yeah.
- --difference came out.
Why don't you tell us
about your time at ESPN?
- Um, well, yeah.
Early on in my career, I
was given the opportunity
to cover the NBA.
And at a time you're
24, 25-year-old coming
in talking about, well, Kobe
Bryant needs to do this,
or LeBron James
needs to do this,
and this person needs to do
this, and this is what I see.
And I remember a producer
pulling me aside and being
like, well, I think you
want to say it like this.
And this is what-- this is the
direction I think you probably
should go in.
And I took a step back.
Because in my mind
I'm thinking, well,
not only have I played
the game at a high level,
I actually have had
conversations with these guys.
And I'm pretty sure
this is what Kobe
would do in this situation.
Or I'm pretty sure
if I went and talked
to Carmelo he was saying this.
But a it was like being
a woman in my opinion,
because I didn't play in the
NBA, and it was only the WNBA,
and didn't matter if I
had an Olympic gold medal,
it still wasn't equivalent
to actually talk
about men's sport over here.
And as the young person
coming in, as you know--
whether it's on air
or in journalism--
you always want to take
the information in.
But at the same time, you
have to have the ability
to have integrity, and know your
craft, and what you're talking
about, and be able to
stand your ground on what
your opinions are.
And I had to learn that
early on in my career.
But that-- the flip
side of that is
when we look at how
women's sports is covered,
it's not covered the same.
And that's always my issue
is that a lot of times
on the entertainment
side of sports
they tell you the stories.
You fall in love with athletes
because you know their stories
or you have a certain team.
And I know I'm in Boston, but I
grew up outside of Pittsburgh.
So you talk about football,
I'm talking about the Steelers.
That's just the way it is, hey.
But I say that to
say is that I had--
I grew up loving that team.
But if I didn't know anything
about the Pittsburgh Steelers,
and I just moved to Pittsburgh,
and they're talking about some
of the players, I'm probably
going to have a connection.
Whereas if you watch women's
sports some of the time,
they're coming--
if the tip is at
7:00 PM, they're
coming on at 6:59 going
right into the game.
They're not telling
you the stories.
They're not really packaging
it like they package the NBA
Eastern Conference finals.
You're going to know when Isaiah
Thomas went to the bathroom
and what new outfit he had.
[LAUGHTER]
And you fall in love with it.
And that's why when I
went into broadcasting
I really wanted to
continue to make sure
that I was pushing hard
for us to tell our stories.
Because it's just as
important for people
to not only love our
sports but to fall in
love with the individuals.
[APPLAUSE]
- Speaking of knowing
the individuals,
I think you had an interesting--
Gevvie had an interesting
experience at a World Cup event
that just showed the
disparity in the attention
that people pay to men's
rowing versus women's rowing.
- Or, yeah, and men's issues
versus women's issues.
- Yes
- At the World Cup
last year in 2016,
the reigning world champion,
Kim Crow, from 2015
had gotten married
over the winter.
And her name was
now Kim Brennan.
And the Australian
team, as is appropriate,
entered her in as Kim Brennan.
And when the referees-- the head
referees and head committee--
was seeding the regatta--
so they rank the top six
athletes--
they hadn't seeded her.
And so we looked
at the heat sheet
and there were three of the
top rowers in one group of six
and where there
should only be two.
And I look at this
and said, oh my gosh,
I'm racing the Olympic champion,
and the world champion,
and me-- and I've been fourth
at the world championships--
in one heat.
Like what is going on?
Freaking out.
I'm texting Kim and
we're texting Mirka
going, how did this happen?
And one person raised their
hand at the coach's meeting--
who also noticed why
isn't Kim Brennan seeded.
And the head of the
seeding committee
said, who is Kim Brennan?
We don't have any
records for her--
in all seriousness.
And the head coach said, that's
Kim Crow, she got married.
And just the thought process
that it wouldn't occur
to them that
Australia had gotten
a new single sculler in one year
whose first name was also Kim?
[LAUGHTER]
And they just couldn't
connect the dots.
And the head of the US team,
who I think-- fortunately
in the US, we do
have a head coach
who is aware of Title
IX and women's issues.
And he just-- he
rolled his eyes.
Mostly it's European
men on the committee.
And the fact that they had this
lack of awareness of things
that women go through and lack
awareness of the women's sport
that they wouldn't have paid
attention to the reigning world
champion and future Olympic
champion that she had gotten
married.
So it was definitely-- we
rolled her eyes and laughed.
And now it's a great story.
- Maura, I'm sure you
walk into a lot of rooms
where you might
be the only woman.
- Yeah, no, absolutely.
Boy, I see it every day.
There's a tremendous
amount of unconscious bias
in our world for all the
gains that we've made.
And there is sexism out there.
And I'll tell you, it's
really interesting.
I see it so pervasively in
my job when I host meetings.
And inevitably vast majority--
if not all-- men coming into
to meet with me, or when
I go somewhere-- but
look at the numbers in
C-suites, among CEOs, boards,
and in elective office.
At all levels, you just
see the dearth of women.
And that matters.
Because that translates
to policy and furthers
disparities and inequalities.
And it comes up
in different ways.
I've got a program in
schools here in Massachusetts
where we're teaching young
people in high school,
empowering them with
the competencies
to take on things like
relationship violence
and dating violence.
And a couple of months
ago I was in a school
and I was listening to a
girl tell the story about how
her boyfriend was trying to
get her to stop playing sports
and just watch his
sporting games.
And that's happening today.
You see a lot of girls
out there playing.
It's so inspiring and wonderful.
But there are
problems that remain.
On the more light, I
remember March Madness
a couple of months ago.
And one of the
political news outlets
tried this game among elected
officials around the country--
send us your brackets.
Now, they only wanted
the men's bracket.
So I sent a men's and a women's.
They didn't print it, but--
[APPLAUSE]
It's just not acceptable.
But it goes to what
both Swin and Gevvie
have been speaking about,
the inequities that exist
in sports for women right now.
When you look at media and
you look at media time,
when you look at advertising
and marketing dollars,
when you look at the collegiate
level and the pro level,
what's happening?
Pay disparities--
we saw it recently
with the women's hockey team.
We've seen it with
the soccer team.
And if you looked at
coaches across this country,
you'd see real disparities in
the collegiate ranks I'm sure.
So we've got we've
got our work to do.
- Yeah, I think it's interesting
you mentioned executives.
One thing that came up in
researching for this panel
is there was a survey
of 400 female executives
and found that 94% of them
played sports, and out
of that number, 52% of them
at the university level.
I know, Swin, you work
a lot with young girls.
Does that just
underscore how important
it is to keep
these girls playing
and to give them opportunities?
Because I think Title IX takes
care of the college level.
But there's a whole
group of youth athletes.
And as I mentioned, girls
drop out two times as much
as boys do.
- I think it's vitally
important to get
young girls involved in sports.
Because a lot of times--
and I know we have some
stage parents where
everybody thinks
that their kid is
going to go pro, which is OK.
It could be your dream, doesn't
mean it's your kid's dream.
But the kids, what
you get out of sports,
it builds character,
bottom line.
You have to learn so many
different disciplines,
whether you're on a team
sport, an individual sport.
There's something you're
going to get that you're
going to have to take
that into the real world,
into the business world.
Now being in the front
office with the New York
Liberty, the one thing that
we look at immediately,
they want to know--
look at your resume.
If you had encountered
sports or played sports
at some type of level,
we're looking at that.
Because that lets
us know that you've
had to go through some things,
you understand teamwork.
There's a lot of
different things
that I learned just
being in sports,
and I'll give a quick example.
When I went to the University of
Connecticut and got on campus,
I came there with
four other girls--
there was five of us that
were in the freshman class.
And we all had
different backgrounds.
One was from the
suburbs in Dayton, Ohio;
I was from Pittsburgh area; we
had somebody from New Jersey.
And then Sue, who was
my college roommate,
was from Syosset, New York.
And I'll never forget--
Sue and I were just
like hot and cold,
everything's
completely opposite.
But we had to learn
how to work together.
And the best thing for
us was that culturally we
came from two different
backgrounds-- family,
upbringing,
economics, everything.
But I learned probably more
from her in four years--
and I think she probably
would say the same--
then anything that I learned
on the basketball court.
Because we had to learn how to
deal with each other, how to
interact, how to work as a team.
And that for me was like
the greatest feeling.
Because I say this
all the time--
diversity, inclusion,
having women on your staff,
having minorities being
part of the conversation,
it gives you more
of a world view
in sports that you then can
use in the corporate world.
[APPLAUSE]
- You seem like
you're nodding, Maura.
Do you have something you want
to add in terms of what you see
and what you-- the lessons
you took from basketball
into the political arena?
- Well, yeah.
I'm new in the political arena.
- You sure you weren't boxing?
You sure you didn't
take up boxing
before you went to
the political realm?
- Well.
No, the good thing--
us little people, we
know how to box out
low and throw elbows.
[LAUGHTER]
And you big people don't get the
ball unless we give it to you.
- Right.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
- No, I think that the
idea about the lessons
is really true.
And I know that just
running for office
there were ups and downs;
there were good polls,
there were devastating polls;
there were a lot of people
who counted me out.
And I think that what I
learned through playing sports
really helped me as I approached
my campaign as a season.
The pundits didn't know that,
but that's how I approached it.
And every day was
like practice--
get out, get after it;
good days, bad days;
and see how it goes; and
always believe in yourself
and always believe
that you can win.
And so that was really
incredibly empowering to me,
though I didn't even
appreciate it at the time.
It was just happening,
and I think the reason--
in addition to having
a lot of good help
from a lot of great people
out across the state--
the reason that I was
successful in running.
But I think that
statistic is interesting.
And I think there's a
lot in that statistic.
Because I think that
you do through sports
learn drive, and discipline,
and goal-setting, and teamwork,
all of these things
that can make
you successful in any
number of environments.
I also sometimes
wonder about the--
a different side of that though.
And that is the presence
of sports in our culture.
On some level, I wonder how many
male CEOs also played sports.
And I wonder if women
coming into the workplace
with a commonality
with male counterparts
helps them advance
at a different pace
or in different ways.
I'm just putting that
out there as a thought.
I don't know if there's any
validity to it whatsoever.
But--
- Makes sense.
- --it's just something
to think about.
- Gevvie, you are--
well actually,
I want to talk a little
bit about women--
and we touched
upon this earlier--
perception, marketing.
I'm looking at Swin.
I know Swin was behind a
campaign for the New York
Liberty.
And I guess Gevvie too, just
in your experience, one,
have you felt any pressure
to be a certain way,
to market yourself
a certain way.
You're in rowing, but you
are in an individual sport.
And when the lights are
on, when the race is on,
it's just you out there.
And there is pressure to get--
I would assume-- sponsors and
people paying attention to you.
- Yeah, I think rowing is such
a small sport that in a way
you're lucky.
You get away from a
lot of the pressure
because not really-- no
one's getting a sponsorship
any way, shape, or know-how.
It's rowing.
- You can hope.
But I think I definitely
see it in other sports.
And I think across the
board at the Olympics
you notice that
female athletes are
more likely to have their hair
done, and their nails done,
and their makeup on.
And it's almost as if their
presence on the playing
field and their performance
isn't enough of a show.
And it's not enough to
look at how fast they run
or how well they
dribble-- they also have
to look good while doing it.
And I think how they play
is the most beautiful thing
about them.
And if they want to
get their nails done
and then put their
makeup on, that's great.
I hope that through
sports women feel
empowered just by the
movement and the performance
and don't feel pressured to
cloud that in any way, shape,
or form with a
ribbon in their hair
or the color of their lipstick.
And I do think you don't
see it the same extent
in male athletes.
[APPLAUSE]
- Any idea how we change that?
Any suggestions?
How do we change the fact--
get people to value
the performance more
than the exterior, so to speak?
Any--
- The thing that
comes to mind was
there was a campaign
for Ask the Athlete--
I think that was the name of it.
And they did a
little clip and they
asked male athletes
questions that they
had asked female athletes.
Did you guys see this?
It was a little
snippet that was done.
And they were asking pro
football players, pro tennis
players all these things
like, oh, can you tell us
about your outfit
today; and, we heard
you broke up with
your girlfriend,
can you tell us the details,
and all these questions.
And the men's faces just
showed disdain or surprise,
and in some cases just reacted
with, like, are you kidding?
And then they revealed that
all these questions that they
were asking were
questions that had
been asked to female athletes.
And a lot of it
comes from what--
how the media portrays
these athletes--
as Swin was talking earlier,
creating a story that
represents the
athlete, not the--
the player, who they
are as a player,
not who they are as a
drama, as a rom com,
or anything like that.
And I think what people ask
to hear-- so it goes back
to both the media and how
they portray it, but also
what people are reading and what
the fans are asking to hear.
So hopefully little
girls are asking
not who made the outfit,
I want to go buy it,
but how many hours do you spend
in the pool and questions that
reflect performance instead
of physical appearance or love
life.
- Yeah, no, I totally agree.
I think there's
two things in that.
I think the people
that are asking
the question, the
journalists that
are trying to get the stories,
are vitally important.
There's a responsibility
that's there.
I also think there's a
responsibility on the leagues
and the individuals.
I know for the WNBA--
I played 15 years in the WNBA
and there was a point just
coming in early on
in my career where
it seemed like our whole
marketing campaign was
based around how we looked.
And the uniforms changed--
they got a little shorter.
And next thing I know when
tucking in my jersey, I'm like,
I tucked in my
jersey my whole life.
Who doesn't tuck in
a basketball jersey?
I just never understood it.
But then you look at
the fact that they
were trying to sell
us as we were feminine
but we still play basketball.
Now granted, I like to dress
up, I like to take pictures.
That may work for me.
But it doesn't mean it
works for all the 144
women that are in the WNBA.
And so I started seeing
like our marketing,
our branding was
putting everybody
into this one box,
which is not fair.
I think we've gotten to a point
now where it's about the game
and how you play the game.
And now you look at the
campaign of Watch me Work
and it's really about watching
how they play basketball.
Whether you like
how they dress up,
whether you like how
they have their hair,
come on watch the
authentic part of the game.
And it took us a while
to get to this place.
But I know for me, working
with the New York Liberty,
it's important that we have
our overarching brand of what
we want our team to be.
But we also have to stay
connected to individually do
the players fit
in that and making
sure we're staying true to
who they are as individuals.
And that's one of
the first things when
I came into the front office--
I wanted to make
sure that I made
that very clear is that
I want to make sure
our brand represents everyone
and it's just not a few.
And I think if every
organization and league take
that responsibility on, I think
we'll be in a better place
and head to the right--
hit it in the right direction.
But you have to think about it.
People are consumers.
And so there's a lot
of different studies
they do nowadays.
And they figure
out how many clicks
it's going to get,
they figure out
how many people
are watching, who's
going to go purchase something.
And a lot of times,
advertisers are
going to go in that direction.
Because it comes back to, as
you know, the bottom line.
- I think the important
phrase that you
said was when I got into the
front office, I did this.
And to me, so much about
what happens in sports
is about women having a voice--
and elsewhere.
I think women having a voice
either in the front office,
or in the attorney
general's office,
and being almost a
final decision-maker.
And it made me think of your
program with Game Changers.
And I'm wondering if you feel
the same way in the sense that
having somebody who's attuned
to the issues a young girl might
face when she--
her boyfriend tells her not
to play sports or just attuned
to different issues that women--
if that makes a difference
and we need to--
it's part of what Title
IX's legacy should,
be which is getting more
women in the front office,
in political office, and if that
needs to be more of a priority
in some ways.
- Well, it does.
Because just having
a law on the books
doesn't do anything by itself.
And we've had Title IX for
a good number of years.
But let's face it--
we still see a lack of
female representation
in legislatures, in
Congress, in elective office,
in boardrooms, and
running corporations.
So we have work to do.
There is something still really
pernicious and real inequity
out there.
Look-- I'm a big
believer in women running
for office at all levels.
Because I think that if
you look at policies,
look at the decision-makers.
I find that picture
staggering of a few weeks
ago with all those men
standing around deciding
what was going to happen
with women's health care.
But as a woman attorney
general, sure, I've
had a particular focus on issues
that have a certain resonance
with me--
human trafficking
and what's happening
to the sexual exploitation
of girls and women;
certainly what's happening
with relationship violence,
and teen dating violence,
and domestic violence;
pay equity-- we worked hard
this year to get a bill through,
it's the first of its
kind in the country;
and certainly issues around
health care and consumer
issues, where
disproportionately women
are the ones who
not only are making
the decisions around
households but are
the ones disproportionately
adversely affected by policies.
So I'm a big one to
say get out there, run,
let's get represented.
People need to hire people.
Take a chance and
hire women, promote
women, whatever
organization you're in.
How ridiculous that you're
going to get somebody
not Swin to do the play-by-play
or cover those games.
Is there anybody who has
more capacity or competence?
No.
But you see this all the time
where fabulous, talented women
with so much--
bringing so much the
table are routinely
passed over for mediocre or
less-than-mediocre males.
[APPLAUSE]
So wherever you have power or
opportunity to hire and promote
women, do that.
And stick by them
and stick with them.
- Swin, what are you doing
in Liberty's front office?
I looked at your staff and I
think you're one of two women--
- Yeah.
- --in the front office.
- Our staff I feel
is very diverse.
I feel good going
into our offices
because I look at some of the
other teams and their staff
and it makes me
laugh a little bit.
But for me, I love
the fact that I
can come in as now a
rookie in the front office,
have these fresh ideas--
this progressive
mindset-- of where
I want to see women's sports go,
and everyone's open to listen.
And yes, I played the
game for 15 years.
But I'll never forget one
of the first meetings I had.
And the young lady
who just got hired,
she had asked, well, what
is it exactly that you do
and what did you study in
school to help you get here?
And I said, well, in school
I studied communications.
But for the last 15 years,
I've not only played basketball
here, I've also
played in Russia,
I played in the Czech
Republic, in China.
15 years I was on executive
board for our committee.
I went through two
CBA negotiations.
I made hires at the union.
I had fires at the union.
I think I've got some background
and qualification to be
able to be here and do this.
But you know as
athletes sometimes they
think because you play
a sport that there's
nothing else you can do.
They put us all into this
box that you're just a jock.
And if you know anything
about female athletes,
it doesn't matter what
level that you're on-- we're
always trying to achieve in
the classroom, in our job.
We love the sport,
we play the sport,
but realistically
we know it's not
going to set us up for life.
We're doing other things.
If you go across the WNBA, you
go across our team in general,
there are women
that own businesses,
there are women who are
in construction right now,
there are women that are
taking their investments
and they're looking
at the markets.
And if people don't open
those doors to give them
an opportunity or a chance,
how can they advance
and how can they bring
the women behind them?
[APPLAUSE]
- You've talked to me about
some interesting solutions.
There was the Instagram.
- Oh, we were talking--
- And to me, this
is interesting too.
So there are big
solutions and then
there are little small ways
in which the bias comes out
against women's athletics.
And sometimes just the
smallest little change
can sometimes have
large ramifications.
And I think that
was what you were
thinking about when you thought
about the Instagram issue.
- Yeah, we were talking
about the university level,
even at an institution
like Harvard,
which definitely values women
as a whole and thinks about it.
Obviously, we're here.
One of our former
captains last year,
who is actually here
tonight, counted up
the pictures in the Harvard
athletics Instagram account.
And it's about 2/3
male, 1/3 female?
And why?
Harvard has an equal balance in
terms of the number of sports
played by women and men.
So shouldn't they represent
those sports equally
and try to increase awareness
of every sport equally?
That's the job of the
athletic department.
And I think as a whole social
media has such an influence
in our world today.
And it is such an easy
thing to tweak in terms
of increasing awareness.
So many people-- you were
talking about clicks.
So many people check Facebook,
check Instagram, check Twitter.
And so when you have
accessibility in something
like that, just making
sure that on all levels
you are increasing
awareness of women and men.
And also creating a--
I think we were talking
about also creating a demand
and placing a value
on women's sports
that's equal to men's sports.
So at Harvard you have to pay
to attend games for more men's
sports than women's sports.
And obviously football throws
that off because there's
no women's football team.
But even if you
eliminate football,
you have to pay to
attend more men's sports
than women's sports.
You pay to attend
men's lacrosse,
you do not pay to attend
women's lacrosse game.
Why?
Why should that be disparity?
If it's a money
thing, then decrease
the cost of a men's ticket and
increase the cost of a woman's
ticket so that they're even.
They should create a demand and
place a value on women's sports
that represents that they
hold the sport in high esteem.
Everyone as a student
athlete, they're
all playing at the same level.
And I think in
order for outsiders
to see that, it can begin
with an institution saying
we value these sports
equally so we are
going to treat them equally.
- One other thing
I'd add is that I
think that we need to find
ways to support women.
Buy season tickets, buy the
package, buy the jerseys.
Have your little sons wearing
jerseys of Liberty players.
That'll be the day.
That's what we want to see.
So where we care
about these issues,
let's put our money, and
our wallets, and our energy,
and our time investing in and
supporting women's athletics.
Take them to girls' high
school soccer games.
Take your kids to college games.
Really support the programs
and grow and create
that demand and that
consumer side of things.
I think that's really important.
I think that we don't
do as much as we could.
- I think that we are heading
in a step in the direction.
I remember the Women's World
Cup, the most recent one,
they didn't make a lot of
the jerseys in men's sizes.
And the men's sizes sold
out instantaneously.
That's a great step.
The company is going, oh,
shoot, we made a mistake.
And I think there was a
public announcement about it.
Because these jerseys were
flying off the shelves.
And it just didn't
occur to whatever
Nike executive to make as many
men's sizes of female jerseys.
Plenty of female
wear Brady jerseys.
Why shouldn't it go
the other way around?
But I think that was definitely
a step in the right direction.
And you're absolutely right.
- Yeah.
And I'll just give you
this brief analogy just
to think about and not
even really answer today.
But just go home
and sleep on this.
Because I had a conversation
during our television
show with our staff.
And we were in the
production room
and we were talking about
how women support the NFL--
which I said earlier I
love my football team
and I'm pretty sure
a lot of you in here
have a football
team you love too.
[LAUGHTER]
But the thing was is
that we were talking--
because all the
domestic violence,
a lot of different things
were happening in the NFL.
But if you looked at their
merchandise, and things
that were being purchased,
and season tickets,
none of that stuff was
really being affected.
And it made me start
thinking about women's sports
and how hard it is for us,
for the New York Liberty,
to get women to come out and
support women at our game,
to buy the jerseys
or buy the tickets.
And there's always a
complaint about, well,
this costs this
amount or that amount.
But I looked over here
at this men's league.
Yes, it's a powerhouse
and it's been there
for a number of years.
But nothing was affecting--
bad news after bad news, it
wasn't affecting their numbers.
And I think about why is that.
And you think about it, because
there's a loyalty to your team,
you love your team.
You may not care what the
rest of the league is doing,
but you feel like this is my
team, I'm connected to it.
So for me, whenever
we get to the point
where all the New York
and around the areas
love the Liberty
and they're going
to support the Liberty, that's
when I'm like, all right,
we're moving in the
right direction.
And I just don't see that
yet of women coming out
supporting women.
The WNBA is the longest
professional women's league
in the world.
Their union is the
longest running union
in the world that's ever been.
And in order for us to keep it
going, for my 13-year-old niece
who's out there with a WNBA
basketball in a gym by herself,
we have to make sure
that we support it.
Because what's going to
happen is if it goes away,
we're going to be marching
up and down the streets
and complaining about
why it didn't last.
But the reality is is not
enough of us are supporting it.
[APPLAUSE]
- That takes me nicely to what
does the future look like.
And after that, we've reached
the point in the program
where it's open to
audience questions.
But I want to know,
what does the future--
Swin, you gave us one
potential scary scenario
of the future, which is people
marching up and down the street
without teams.
But what does women's sports--
what does college
sports look like,
what do professional
sports look like?
Are we ever going to have that
big moment where the pro sports
and college sports get
the kind of support
that we thought they would get
coming out of the Women's World
Cup in 1999?
And I open it to all of you to
look into your crystal ball.
- I'm just a firm believer in
the fire that's in our country
right now.
And I just believe--
and I said this, and no
disrespect to the men in here,
but this is just the
year of the woman.
And it's time for
us to take the torch
and move it forward in
all aspects of business,
and sports, and everything else.
Because there just comes
a time and a moment--
and I think we're in it--
where you have to just stand up.
And my mom used to
always say to me
if you don't stand
for something,
you're going to
fall for anything.
And that's how I live
my life, that right
now when I speak
out, when I stand up
for things that are good or bad,
I understand it's not for me.
It's for all of the girls
that are coming up behind me.
And I think if we
have that mindset,
I'm starting to
feel like there's
more of a collective with that.
There could be
teams-- there could
be the soccer team
it's a moment, the USA
team it's a moment.
I think right now our
country's just in that moment.
And so for me, I hope
this year of the woman
is an invigorating thing that
we'll all grab ahold with
and run with it.
The greatest thing for me
was I spoke at a university
with Dante Stallworth,
who is a friend of mine.
And he actually played
here before too.
And he said, yeah,
I can say it--
he said to the class,
I'm a feminist.
And that just really rocked me.
I thought that was pretty cool.
Because I've never heard a guy
just come right out and say it.
But I'm glad that men are
comfortable saying I support
women and being OK with that.
So I hope that's the
direction we're going in.
- Thoughts?
- Yeah I'm optimistic
in longer term.
I think as we get farther from
Title IX and more and more
women participate
in sports, it also
is more of an opportunity
for women to become coaches.
I think as a rower
being in rowing now,
rowing has been an NCAA
sport for about 20 years now.
And more and more women are
entering the coaching ranks.
And I think I've been very
fortunate as an athlete
to be coached by two
very strong women
and coached under a
very strong woman.
I think the head coaches
are still mostly men.
And as it is at NCAA
sport and as we progress,
a lot of the assistant
coaches are female.
And when you get a female mentor
and a female head coach and you
see that female in
a position of power,
I think you can connect on
a level that you can't--
there are a lot of
great men's coaches,
but you just don't see them
as a role model in the way
that you can see a
strong women's coach.
And I think as we get
further from Title IX,
hopefully get more and more
females in those coaching
roles, hopefully coaching not
only females but also males.
It can definitely--
why not go both ways?
- Yeah.
Because now I think the number--
the latest statistic I saw
was that more than
60% of college
coaches across all
divisions are actually men.
So women's coaches, yeah.
What do you see in
the future, Maura?
- Well, I think there
is going to be still
a need to ensure
accountability and specifically
enforce the law.
I think we're going
to see more lawsuits.
I think that with this
energy, with this movement,
people are going to realize,
and look for, and appreciate
some more of the inequalities
that exist even with Title IX.
And I don't think
that's a bad thing.
Because I think about
those women at Brown
many years ago who
brought the fight.
And if it wasn't
holding organizations,
institutions accountable in a
very real way, in a way that
impacted prestige
or bottom line,
we would not have seen
some of the advances.
That's just the way it goes.
So I actually think
we're probably in a time
where we're going to see
some more litigation based
on existing disparities.
I also think that it is
optimistic where we're at.
I think more women and more
girls are playing sports.
I think that it's right we
have a concern about the lack
of women coaching right now.
And what we've seen in
terms of the trend there,
that's an issue.
I think about what Title
IX gave women access to
in terms of this license, this
freedom to not just get out
there and compete but to sweat.
You think about
us, I think we're
a healthier population for
it and much better off.
And I'm heartened you know when
I think about-- just a couple
of weeks ago, I was in a
classroom down on the South
Shore.
And I went around the room
to a group of third graders.
And I'm asking all
of them what they
wanted to be when they grow up.
And of course you know
any number of the boys
were pro baseball player,
pro soccer player.
I try to encourage them
to keep their options open
with a backup plan.
[LAUGHTER]
Especially the boys,
they just don't see it.
But I got to this little girl.
Her name was Cally.
And she was sitting there.
And she said she wanted to go--
she a basketball player,
she's going to go to UConn,
and then she's
going to play pro.
So I think about
people like Swin
blazing the trail for that
little third grader today.
And that leaves me optimistic
about where we're going to go.
- And now I guess we'll turn--
there are microphones being
placed.
So anyone who has a
question for the panelists,
please step up to the
microphone and ask away.
- My daughter is 29 now.
But when she was about--
I don't know-- seven, we started
watching women's basketball,
college basketball.
So Geno Auriemma
is like the father.
I think he's the one exception
with the male coaches--
I think.
But I want to know--
there's always been this woman
next to him, long blond hair.
And she seems to be a
very important person.
She's been there for years.
So what would you say about
her and what's her name?
I want to give her some--
- I'm going to have to
text her after this.
[LAUGHTER]
Why else did you stay
with him for 30 years?
You're just now the little
blond woman back there.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, we call we call her CD.
Her name is Chris Dailey.
She actually played
basketball at Rutgers.
Yes, she's very tall.
She played basketball
at Rutgers.
She actually came in with him.
And they together built
it from the ground up.
She doesn't get enough credit.
But I think over the years
any time players have
been interviewed-- any
time I've been interviewed,
I never just mention him
without mentioning her.
Because to me they're
a package deal.
To me and I say
this to his face--
he doesn't get to where
he's at without her.
And a lot of people
are like, well,
why didn't she go
be a head coach?
She enjoyed her role
and her position there.
And I respect her for that.
She just never felt--
as she would tell
you if she was here--
that there was a job
that was right for her.
And so what I learned
from her at UConn
was about who I was
as a person when
we step onto the court, when
we travel, how we got dressed,
how we went to banquets.
She's the one-- the
mastermind behind
when we walk into a building and
we have UConn across our chest,
she's the one that was
molding all of that.
So when you talk about that
role model, that mother
figure, the things
that he was never
really strong in that
area, Chris was there.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- Well, if you ever notice if
he's about to get a technical
and he's about to
get to half court,
she's the one that's
piddle-paddling out there
to really get him.
They have a great relationship.
But yeah, she's like--
if there's the godfather,
she's like the godmother
of UConn I guess.
But yeah, she plays a vital
role for that university.
- I was thinking
about Gevvie's comment
about how the women felt
they had to dress, and look,
and show themselves
in a certain way
even though they were
Olympic athletes.
And I'm wondering why
we haven't commented
on the role of homophobia and
its effect on women's sport.
- Well, that's a great question.
I can take that head-on.
Because we get it in the WNBA.
And I've asked the question.
I did a piece with
The Players' Tribune--
Tanisha Wright, Essence Carson.
And we asked those
questions of why don't we
get the same
recognition, why is it
so hard for people to have
an appetite for the WNBA.
And there's two
different things--
people who have a problem with
the LGBTQ community and people
who have a problem with majority
of the league being minority.
And until we have
those conversations
and be able to talk
about those things,
it's really hard for
you to address them.
And it's not taboo.
It's what it is.
And I love the fact that we're
a diverse group of women.
But if you just focus
on the basketball,
that's what it should be on.
But people are scared to
have those conversations.
But our players aren't
scared to have it.
Our players support
across the board everyone.
And I think that's been one
of the issues in the WNBA.
And I can give you a
quick example, because I
want to let you ask
you your question,
is that the US
women's team has won
six Olympic gold
medals in a row,
just as dominant as UConn--
six Olympic gold
medals in a row.
We're close friends and
love the US soccer team.
If you watch how our US soccer
team, from sponsorship to when
it's Olympic time, the
packages that are put around
and the women, and it's like
that's their time of year--
it is not the same with our
jewel, I feel, of US basketball
with six Olympic gold medals.
Because that is
the goal, correct?
If you're an Olympian,
you want to try
to get to the pinnacle
of reaching gold medals.
And so we asked the
question of why not us.
And this was two Olympics ago--
why not us?
And if you look at our US
women's basketball team,
for a number of years
it's very diverse.
We have women who are not afraid
to say, yes, I'm a lesbian,
yes I have a
partner, and it's OK.
And for some of our friends
who are on the soccer team, who
also may have a partner,
they may not feel comfortable
being able to say that
or do it because they're
getting packaged and
put in a way that
is completely different.
So I do think that that
is an issue that we
have to address and talk
about in order for us
to kind of push that aside,
and let the sport just
be the sport, and
not make it about all
these different
political issues.
- And I think that a
couple of things on this.
Look, I remember playing.
I remember high school and in
college homophobic comments,
and characterizations,
and slights.
And it just-- it was just part
of the scene, I feel like,
until--
until-- there was actual legal
action and there ended up being
more legal action in this
country establishing rights--
greater rights and
protections for LGBT people.
And I'm a beneficiary of that.
But make no mistake about
it-- the homophobia is still
very real.
And so it's not just
limited to sports.
Look at society right now.
When we have this
misogynous-in-chief in charge
of the White House, when we
have an attorney general,
United States Attorney
General, whose first act
was to rescind the guidance
for LGBT students' protections
in schools.
These are not good signals.
But make no mistake about it--
they reflect a homophobia that
is still existing across
any number of industries,
and sectors, and
spaces, and-- yeah--
on the court and
in the ball field.
It's hard being a
woman athlete, it's
hard being a gay woman athlete.
It's hard being a
woman coach, it's
hard being a gay woman coach--
harder, I think.
So to me it just
points to the work
we've got to do as a
society and as a culture.
And that starts with
repudiating and rejecting
racism, sexism, homophobia,
you name it in all forms
whenever we see it.
[APPLAUSE]
- I want to go back to body
image for just a moment
but take it in a
different direction.
I worked at Sports Illustrated
as one of their women
reporters in the 1970s.
And I remembered that it was
very rare for women to be
on the cover of our magazine
then except in mid-February
when we did the--
[LAUGHTER]
--we did the bathing suit issue.
What I want to swing
back around too
now is if we look at Sports
Illustrated's bathing suit
issue this year, we
will find that there
are less of a bathing
suit on all of the models.
But surprisingly, we will
find that in those pages
there are the two top US
gymnasts from the Olympics--
Simone and Aly-- who are
both posed in deliberately--
and they speak about this on
their Instagram and the rest--
to show the muscularity
of their bodies.
Because they feel as though,
particularly in their sport,
it's been the pixie
girl who leaps up
and the muscularity isn't
really a part of what they are.
So in effect they're
showing off their bodies
and displaying them in this
traditionally very misogynistic
way.
But I do want to
compare that to the fact
that in so many other instances
you do see female athletes very
scantily clad and very
much posing in ways
that are very predictable.
They're almost ways
that models would
have posed in those
swimsuit issues years ago.
So I think we're
seeing this duality
of how we think about body
image of women athletes.
And I'd just like
your thoughts on that.
- Can I say something first?
So, Melissa, before
you sit down,
just to recognize Melissa.
In case, you don't know
who Melissa is, It's
Melissa Ludtke, personal hero.
And she is one of the pioneers
in women's sports journalism.
Because she sued the major
league baseball commissioner
for locker room access in 1977.
[CHEERING]
And won, and won.
[APPLAUSE]
Reaction to what Melissa said
or comments on the duality?
- Gosh.
I think not just as athletes,
but maybe athletes because we
are in the position of being
in minimal clothing frequently
and shown in minimal clothing
frequently-- as a rower,
we wear unisuits.
You can see everything
in a unisuit.
And it does create
a self-consciousness
about body image.
And Simone and Aly have
both been very vocal--
not just through that
picture, but also
through Twitter, and Instagram,
and the like-- about the fact
that they've
received negative fan
feedback about their
muscles and also expressing
a pride for those muscles.
It takes a lot of work
to build those muscles.
That's purposeful.
And I think that they are
a little bit a younger
generation.
And I hope that they're
representative of the girls who
are coming through.
As one of the
coaches at Radcliffe
this year, you'd see it
in college athletes still.
You see an awareness of what
their body type is compared
to other students on campus,
an awareness of muscles,
issues around eating.
And I think it is a problem.
How to fix it right
away, I don't know.
But I think Simone and Aly are
taking an awesome first step.
- Yeah, I think--
you see it a lot even
with Serena Williams.
And she constantly gets
talked about her muscles 24/7.
But Serena also
likes to dress up
and she likes to be in gowns.
And there's always something
that's said about her body.
I'm all for--
I don't care what age
you are as a woman
to be empowered by your body.
And what I do with my body, how
I-- my body image is up to me.
And I love the fact
to see athletes
embracing that and showing
their strength in it
however they do it.
I do think that you can tell
when somebody is only doing it
because they're collecting a
check versus somebody that's
doing it because it's
empowering to them
and they're sending
out a certain message.
And maybe it's not so clear,
but it's pretty clear for me.
And as someone that
when I was younger,
I used to do runway modeling.
And when I went into basketball,
I never wanted to touch that.
I didn't want to always
go to the feminist where
I like to wear dresses and
do this because I thought
that people looked
at me as being weak,
because that was a
side of me that they
didn't necessarily always see.
So I stayed away from that.
And then I just
started embracing it,
like this is who I am, OK.
If I want to wear these type
of clothes and everything,
that's who I am.
So I thought what they did
in regards to this swimsuit
was pretty awesome.
And I just think
we have to take it
for what it is because people
do it for different reasons.
- Yeah, no, I totally--
I respect that.
I think though that the--
I guess I think the
swimsuit edition is
ridiculous in the sense that--
[APPLAUSE]
And I am all for women
showing off their muscles,
and being proud of their
bodies, and just go for it.
That's awesome to me.
But sometimes I wonder--
are we that
surprised that people
weren't apoplectic over
the fact that the Ray Rice
video or that pervasive domestic
violence or sexual assault
has been allowed to occur
in the NFL over the years
without any sort of
accountability or retribution?
Who is actually
getting that magazine,
and exactly what is that
reader, and what are they
taking as a message from that?
And I think that this is
part of society's ownership.
We can talk a big game
about a lot of stuff.
But let's face the
reality of some
of what's right in front
of us with some of this.
- Thank you for this
very good conversation.
I wanted to ask a somewhat
different question.
Understandably, at
this 45th anniversary
we are celebrating Title IX
and we are focusing on the ways
that women's athletics deserves
to get a share of the pie.
And we want it to be
recognized and in many ways
to mimic male sports.
But male athletics
aren't necessarily
the panacea in all ways.
And male relationships around
sports aren't always ideal.
There's bullying,
there's exclusiveness,
there's stigmatizing
of people who aren't
competitive in the same ways.
So I'm wondering if--
what your thoughts are about
the ways in which women's sports
may be different
than men's or should
aspire to be different
than men's athletics.
- I think you
should aspire to be
the best player in your sport.
I think that's what we train for
is to be the best in our sport.
I can use basketball.
And as analogy, I think people
always talk about, well,
the women-- the WNBA
isn't as good as the NBA
because they don't dunk.
And I always ask the
question, are you
watching the Golden
State Warriors right now,
what do you like about them?
And people tell me,
guys will be like,
oh man, they pass the ball,
they share, they shoot threes,
it's unbelievable.
You see that behind
the back play--
pass?
And then I'll say, well,
you know that the women
do all that right?
You didn't mention
dunking one time.
So now it's a thing of beauty
when the men are doing it
in Golden State.
And I'm like, women have been
playing fundamental basketball
forever.
So I just think that
women have to just
be the best they can
be, grow the league.
You're seeing younger
girls starting there really
have a vision and aspire
to being in the WNBA
at a younger age.
So they're working
on their craft.
The game is faster, women
are taller, quicker.
That's what we want to see.
I don't want there to be a
comparison always to the NBA.
Because at the end
of the day, I do
think earlier on in our
career right now in the WNBA,
we have women that understand
their place is also role models
and wanting to set an
example for the future.
Whereas if you look back
when the NBA started out--
which was on tape delay, we
have a TV deal right now--
but they started 20
years in and there
was a lot of stuff that
happened with the NBA
before it got to where it's at.
People forget that.
So I think in its
infancy for me,
I just want to see women's
sports continue to grow
and be the best that it can be.
- I also think
that while men's--
I would never encourage bullying
and anything on that extreme,
I think that competition is
something that women should not
shy away from.
And I think in your
comment it to me
implied that women should
be happy all the time
and always get along.
No-- I think that one of the
best things about sport for me
was learning how to
fail and learning how
to receive negative feedback.
I think those are
two of the biggest
lessons I learned from sport.
My college coach was not
nice to me a lot of the time.
- Join the club.
- And I learned a lot from that.
[LAUGHTER]
I am a much stronger person
today and a much better rower
because of that.
And I think not being
handled with gloves--
like you can't just
handle with gloves
because they're a female.
I think it's OK to be
brutal and be honest.
And occasionally we need that.
I think sports is
an environment where
it's in a venue of it's own.
My college coach wouldn't
be mean to me because
of who I am as a person.
She would be harsh because
I was rowing incorrectly.
And I think being able
to separate those two
and have an environment
in which you can learn
those lessons of
failure and criticism
in a healthy environment
is really important.
And I don't think that
something being hard, or tough,
or failure is anything
that we should
try to correct about
women's sports.
It shouldn't be a happy go
lucky, we love the team,
we're going to win all the time.
Because then you're not
going to learn anything.
I think there is something
about the harshness of sport
which is why we're here today.
- Title IX is not
just about sports too.
That's another thing.
This whole thing was--
there was a point to it, right?
This was about equality
of opportunity, right?
And so it's sports, it's
activities, it's programming.
We're talking about
the context of sports.
But make no mistake about it--
we get too few women in STEM.
There's a lot of work we need
to do on a lot of fronts.
And Title IX is there,
needs to be enforced,
needs to be supported.
But let's recognize too
that the goal of this
was really about
equality of opportunity.
- So my question is
unintentionally related.
I think in the last
couple of years
you've seen a growth
and a rise in women
in leadership and coaching
in men's sports teams.
What role do you think
that kind of presence
in sport in general and
visibility on that level
plays in relation
to this as well?
- It's great.
I think it reflects that
more women are in sport,
and that they don't see a
barrier to participating
in men's sports, and
they're not intimidated
by trying to participate
in men's sports.
And I think some
of that confidence
is probably from being
an athlete themselves--
that's just a guess,
I don't know that.
But I think youth--
as Shira said, there are so many
men coaching women's sports,
why not have it the
other way around.
Women approach the game
differently, as Swin said.
So if women are better at
these behind the back passes
and three pointers, why not have
a woman coaching a men's team?
That's something they might be
able to contribute to a men's
team, change the game so you're
seeing it from another angle.
And it can only
benefit everyone.
- Yeah.
And I always say when you
think about a women's team
and they hire a male
coach, they never
get the why are they hiring
a male coach to coach
this women's team,
this is crazy.
They never get that.
But as soon as you hear
the potential for a woman
to coach in the NBA,
people are, that's
ridiculous, why would a
woman coach in the NBA.
Well right now you
have Becky Hammon who's
on the staff with the Spurs.
But Adam Silver, the
commissioner of the NBA,
recently said, I expect for--
at some point soon for
a woman to be coaching--
a head coach in the NBA.
I'm just waiting
for us to equal out
on a collegiate level,
high school level.
We might get to--
the pros may have
it before we start
talking about it on that level.
And I think that's
what we need to stop
looking at the
male versus woman,
and start thinking about
what kind of coach are you,
and give more women these
opportunities because they
can coach.
I know some women
that know football
better than some of the coaches
they got on their staff.
And I'd be like go get her.
So I think that's an area that
you're hitting right on that we
need to look at as well
when we talk about Title
IX and those issues.
- You bring up Becky
Hammon and the Spurs.
And I think one of
the interesting things
about that situation is that
it's Greg Popovich who's
considered to be the
best NBA coach around
and that he's saying
she's qualified,
I want her on my
staff, I want her front
and center sitting on the bench
and instructing my players.
And I think that's another
important part of the equation.
What I loved about the
opening weekend of the WNBA
is you had a lot
of the NBA players
coming out and saying how
much they love the WNBA game.
So I think that's
another side of it
too where we have to have--
we can't ignore the men.
You know they have to be part
of the support in driving people
towards the women's game.
Can't just be women
buying the jerseys.
It has to be the men and people
like Greg Popovich saying, hey,
this is quality right here.
- But also too
think about this--
whether it's in college--
and you know this as
well-- whether it's
in college or pros, when your
athletes, your student athlete,
male and female, they
talk to each other
and you support each other.
We don't get that
kind of divisiveness.
A lot of times it's the
people who didn't play sports
or now you're covering sports
and you have these opinions.
But I go to the
Olympics and it's
all of the athletes
supporting each other.
It's our men and women's
basketball team literally
supporting each other.
We get text messages from
some of our NBA friends
that are watching the game.
And it's like other people
who are covering our sport
need the men's invalidate
the fact that we're good.
And I'm like, no, we're good.
You just haven't caught up yet.
And I think that unfortunately
that's the reality of it.
And we live in that space.
And I say it all the
time, I get tweets
and I get social media from guys
that I guarantee you probably
couldn't run up and
down the court one time
but he's criticized every single
thing about what a woman did
and how she plays.
And I'm like, you didn't even
play intramurals, did you?
[LAUGHTER]
You didn't really.
But that's what happens.
So yeah.
I'm sorry, go on.
Sometimes I can vent about that.
[LAUGHTER]
- Hi.
I was actually a plaintiff
on that Brown case.
So thank you for acknowledging
that very complex experience
for a freshman in college.
- Hi, Jennifer--
Jennifer [INAUDIBLE].
- I'm also a full-time
working mom of three
in a male-dominated industry.
I sit in a lot of panels like
this thinking about action.
I'm actually optimistic.
But I'm also frustrated
because I think
we have a lot still to do.
And there's opportunity,
and exposure,
and continuing the
conversation, and equal pay.
And it's like where do we start.
And I would love to know your
opinion on what do you go back
and do right after this panel.
Because I know I have my own
answers to that question.
But where do we start and how--
where do we make the
most impact right away?
- One thing--
everything is local.
So look at your kid's
school, mm know look
at what's going on there for
programming and opportunity.
Is it equal or is it not equal?
What do we need to do?
Look at what's
happening at work.
When I started, I did
a training in my office
on unconscious bias.
I think every
employer in this state
should be doing a training
on unconscious bias.
Every employer in
the state ought
to have programs on
diversity and inclusion.
If you're in a workplace,
ask that of your employer
or form a group to
go to your employer
and demand that kind of
action and assessment.
We passed an equal pay
law here in Massachusetts.
Make sure that your employer
is actually enforcing that
and paying attention to that.
And I think the point
about where you invest--
are you taking kids to
see women and girls, say,
in sports-- and this is a
sports-specific comment.
But are you taking
them to games,
are you exposing them to games?
If they're interested, are
you exposing-- not just
girls, boys most
importantly, are
you exposing your young boys,
or nephews, or grandchildren
to women's athletics?
When you go into the bar or
restaurant later on tonight
or this week and there--
try this on, it's fun--
make them watch-- you guys
play what night, Thursday?
- Yep, Thursday.
- Flip that channel over, OK.
- ESPN2.
- And make them watch ESPN2.
[APPLAUSE]
And just find ways
to act locally.
Where can you bring this
and where can you subtly
raise and elevate attention
and grow awareness.
Those are some things that I
think about to start anyways.
- Yeah, no, I totally agree.
The first thing I did
whenever I retired--
and even during
my playing career,
but when I retired, I tried
to figure out where could I
reach my hands out to,
where do the tentacles go
that I'm able to touch
the people around me.
And that's who I
want to affect first.
Because then I know they're
going to touch the next 10
people out there.
And just try to have
change every day.
Because I think the small--
sometimes you-- we think
about the big picture
and it's overwhelming.
But if I think about
within our organization
am I changing
someone's mindset, am
I helping them see
something differently,
am I invested in
pouring into our players
so that they're becoming better
leaders so that they can go out
there and be able
to speak and talk
about these different topics.
Do they know their
history enough
to be able to speak on it?
Small things like that I
think are so important.
That's where you can start.
Because every day you're
going to get up and feel good
that, you know what,
I'm chucking away at it,
I'm chucking away at it.
Until you get in a
room like this and we
all have the same goals.
And then that's when you
really just have a big impact.
- I think social media makes it
really easy in some senses too.
I think when you read stories
about the US women's hockey
team or the US
women's soccer team,
post, re-post, share
it with their people.
Make sure that that link
in The Times or The Globe
is clicked on and it
comes up in the five read
headlines of the day.
Just promote women's sports
and women in general.
- Demand that your community
newspapers put women--
girls-- on the sports pages, OK?
You can all pay
attention to that too.
- Right.
- Hi.
I just have a suggestion.
I am all for all
this we want this,
we want that, we want that.
But where is the action?
And I have taken time--
I think the most important
thing in any kind of business--
because sports is a
business, it's money,
at the end of the day
it's an economic question.
And every time you
have limited resources,
there's going to be two
forces at least fighting
for those resources.
In order to get them, the person
who has them in their hands
has to release them
either because they're
going to get something out
of what they're giving it to
or because the other
party has found out
how they're going to get
those resources from them.
Sports runs on endorsement
funding and sponsorship deals.
And a lot of times
that has already
gone to the male sports.
I think the women's
sports should go back
to a drawing board--
how do we invite and sustain
funding in women's sports
at a micro level?
We want to go for big funding.
For example, I'll
give an example.
Boston Breakers has
just announced today
they got Dunkin' Donuts
on board for them,
which is a big achievement.
But that doesn't
happen every day.
But I looked at their packages--
anybody with $5,000 can
not invest as a partner
in the Boston Breakers.
And a lot of people are
tired of being consumers.
They want to have a vested
interest in our team.
They want to be stockholders
or stakeholders in a team.
If we would give opportunities
to mothers and smaller funders
to come in as stockholders,
just like startups operate,
and allow this to
grow, eventually
if somebody has put their
time in a team, rain or shine
they're showing up.
They're going to make sure there
is a buzz in the newspaper,
they're going to make sure
every politician in that area
is paying attention
to what's happening,
they're going to hold
them accountable--
if you do not pay
attention to my team,
I'm not giving you my vote.
So ultimately it
comes down to are
you allowing this person to own
a portion of women's sports.
And that's what I think we
should take from this level.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I think that's an
interesting concept.
And I'll just wrap up this
panel with this thought.
When we were organizing this,
I was emailing some people
I know in the community,
some longtime head
coaches of women's sports.
And one of them was a woman
who has coached forever
in Massachusetts high
school athletics--
[INAUDIBLE]
I don't know if
she's here tonight.
She said she was going to come.
But she said to me,
well, couple of things.
First of all, I think I played
basketball in this gym way
back when once upon a time.
And she said, also, I'm
really happy that you're
organizing an event like this
because it's about vigilance.
And it's about
vigilance not just
when it's the 45th anniversary
of Title IX coming up,
or when we're gearing
up for an Olympic year
and women seem to take center
stage in Olympic years,
or when there's a Women's
World Cup going on.
And I think that's an
important takeaway, which
is it's about vigilance.
It's about having
conversations like this
all the time, year
round, every year.
And it doesn't have to be
a special anniversary year.
It should just be.
And with that, I would
like to again thank
Radcliffe, and WBUR,
and two special people--
Amy McDonald and Becky Wassarman
who have been by my side as we
took this from
conception to reality.
So thank you and thank
you all for coming.
And thank you to the panelists--
[APPLAUSE]
Maura, Gevvie, and Swin,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]